[Music]
so couple things in the news we need to
comment on john like last week we talked
about the uh government um basically
states attorneys general several of them
banded together and sued navient for
what it may be one of the largest
settlements in u.s history navient being
required to settle for 1.83 billion
dollars
and 95 million of that was uh in
restitution 1.7 billion was in student
loans that had to be forgiven because
they were fraudulently
made or fraudulently managed
and we made a lot of fun with that and
had a lot of fun with that because it's
it's absolutely a bizarre thing that
navient just got
they got clocked i mean they got their
clock cleaned one of the largest
billions and billions and billions
naviance forgiveness is now more than
the federal government's forgiveness of
student loans but they didn't do
anything wrong but they didn't admit
anything wrong now here's what's
ridiculous though okay
here's how people here's how the media
and i swear some of you people
so you would think that the headline
would read
navient
is a fraudulent scumbag
a bunch of trainees yes that ripped
people off and the government took them
down
instead cnn says more than four hundred
thousand student loan borrowers will get
debt relief from navient what a gift
like navient is just
a charitable organization thank you cnn
for your misleading headline
now when you read down in the cnn
article it actually does say that they
were sued yeah but you know the uh but
the headline is like navient is a
charitable organization oh you know we
just thought we wanted to help
because we're just those kind of people
in bc navient plans to cancel some
student loan borrowers loan debt i
wonder who qualifies thanks headline
thanks that's awesome
that great they're just they're just the
best people
you're losing your mind out there
america
why would nbc and cnn do that you would
think they would take the side of the
consumer and go crooks caught on tape
your loan might be forgiven because they
were sued into oblivion
you know instead it's like
navient is going to help you
it's like
jeez man come on guys you finally get a
real bad guy
yeah and you don't even know what to do
with him
you finally get a bad guy that you
didn't make up you got a real one and
then we let it just roll off
and then this is this is just
so i'm there was a little uh
a kids game
on the internet uh an app or uh
i don't even know what it was i think it
was called animal farm okay and you
would build your little farm is that
right james it's called animal farm
you remember what i'm talking about
animal crossing is what we're hearing
crossing or something like that it was
like this empire thing or something but
you built your farm
and you you tilled the farm
and you know you eventually you know and
you made like
pretend internet money that didn't exist
that's what it is
farmville that's what it was called and
your kid could spend you know and then
it got to where you could actually go on
the site and give real money
to get pretend money
to buy a pretend pig
i make my kids go outside and work a
real garden but this is like this is
like a virtual pig it's not a pig okay
it's a virtual pig it's a pretend pig it
doesn't really exist it exists only
on the internet it's not there's no
oinking no bacon gonna happen okay
just a just a it's a virtual pig it's
not real and you could build your whole
farm out with this and it was all
pretend and it was all virtual and it
was a kid's game and so i run into this
guy at an entree leadership event
and i'm like it's him the guy that
created the game no no
the kid's 19 years old and his dad's
with him and his older brother who's 26
is there and i'm like so what kind of a
business you all got well we build uh
apps for farmville
and i'm like you mean like add on like
you don't you don't own farm bill no but
we we help people
do better at their farm their pretend
farm that's not really there
and i'm like really
and so how much do you make he goes well
i made six million dollars last year
on this app my dad works for me and so
is my older brother he's 19.
and i'm going crazy i thought it was the
neatest
thing that this young entrepreneur could
figure out a way
to sell an app on pigs that aren't
really there and get real money and got
real money
and kids are paying them serious money
to get what is happening
that's not really there well then it
started occurring to me that we now have
an entire
probably two generations that are raised
up with a screen in front of their face
and to them what's on that screen is as
real as the real thing
when you say virtual
to someone my age it means not real it's
a projection it's sort of it's virtual
it's not if i
virtually made it i didn't make it
okay if i if you know i didn't get there
you know what i'm saying that's the
literal definition only have a million
dollars no you don't it means you don't
and so
um and so that that's uh that means you
have maybe a little bit less but not
quite you know you're not it's not real
you're not there and so when you say
virtual now to this entire two
generations
to them it's very real because they've
lived their entire life in it
and so when meta hits
and now we're selling nfts and
now walmart and nike
and
under armour are selling nfts and
now you can
walmart's setting up now for you to have
your
your pretend house it's not really there
it's only on the internet like your
little farm bill
and if you want to buy pretend drapes to
go in your pretend house because that's
what virtual means it means pretend not
real it's not really there there's
nothing there it's it's not real it's
virtual
and but now walmart is setting up
appears to be venturing into the
metaverse with plans to create its own
cryptocurrency and collection of nfts
the big box retailer filed several new
trademarks last month that indicates its
intent to make and sell
virtual
goods let me help you with this
virtual goods is an actual oxymoron if
it's a good it's not virtual
and if it's virtual it's not a good a
good this little coffee cup right here
is an actual coffee cup it actually
exists here's some of the goods
including virtual electronics virtual
home decorations virtual toys virtual
sporting goods and so what we've got is
the kids that grew up playing farmville
are now going to virtually furnish their
virtual house at walmart
oh my gosh
well they didn't pay off their student
loans they don't even live in the real
world they virtually live
because it's safer in there inside that
little box than it is out here with the
with the crazy button with humans with
real drapes that fall off real windows
well and try hanging real drapes that'll
help you get a divorce but yeah exactly
just i mean but these drapes virtually
hang themselves it's happening
this is yeah yeah unless you have to
hire alone is there not a psychological
disorder at play here
dude we we have i'm telling you it's
escape man it's escaping to a fantasy
world checking out of the challenges of
our real world and we're going to a
place where we can control the variables
because we cannot do it in our real life
that's exactly right
and now we're spending money to do it
real real real money for things that
aren't really there there in case
anyone's forgotten we're in not real
money
to the tune of
what 20 25 trillion dollar like yeah
well there's just so virtual that we're
just moving none of it's real anymore
but uh well your generation did that
well that's true my generation did do
that but
last 10 years we've doubled the uh
you know 10-year look back thing that's
going around yeah you doubled the uh
the debt at the government level that's
another discussion but oh my god this is
so this is uh i rarely say i'm not
saying it's not okay to play video games
and if you want to spend some money on
your video games or whatever that's fine
but when you psychologically escape to
another world to the point that you
don't own real drapes but you bought
grapes in your pretend house you got
issues from electronic walmart darling
it ain't real
sounds like my aunt
i don't even know what
what do you say to this
it's virtual
it's virtually oh it's not real but it's
so interesting because it's the kid made
so much money i'm so enthralled with it
but it's scary by what it means to about
this generation